all right so in this technique he can't
push okay and and in no point no point
in the move can he push he can't can't
push or drive so it's visible he can't
come forward at no point in the
technique no point in the technique has
nothing to do with my movement you see
nothing to do with my movement and then
I can bring him forward though I'm
bringing him forward okay
one don't just open the technique oh
holy okay right at the beginning you
have seized the center B you seize the
center and now you're moving the center
you're doing what you want to do to
it
because
because you have to get his his
Center
past the axis of rotation stay
there this is where he has to be okay if
his Center
is south of the axis of rotation he can
turn into it this is a
counter so if I go
here and I enter he can turn with me you
see he Center how P me and it's not by
me getting out of the way cuz he's in
control of his body so he could stop
himself I just get it out of the way he
stops himself he can
turn you see that's what everyone does
in the choreograph to chemy for their
front breakfall Okay but
I'm going to bring him back I'm throwing
him back there past me you guys see that
but at no point could he over accelerate
the degree at which I'm bringing him uh
the rate at which I'm bringing him
forward nor can he under penetrate the
degree of penetration that I want to do
okay but you have to not do the
form and you're just like there's the
throw does
whatever you want to think martially and
energetically but he has to go past
me
okay
okay all
right so I'm going to
rotate I don't want to double rotate so
or double weight on my rotation so I'm
not going to keep the line of gravity
between my two feet and turn my feet
like
this I'm going to shift on the back foot
the and single pivot single pivot on the
back foot boom boom stay on the back
foot okay until he's around then I'll sh
back on the other
foot so here's double
pivot oh that's
crazy and we single pivot single
pivot back foot turn front foot back
foot
again do it one more time sorry
so right foot I'll say right foot so
single pivot right foot single pivot
Left
Foot Right Foot left foot
in Left Foot Right Foot
[Music]
in
to come back on that
foot crazy I got no
power right
foot left
foot Left Foot Right
Foot
[Music]
he has to still get past
you right
foot left foot
past you you you'll always have like and
again we don't know we just use Andrew's
figure the smartest one so he he said
the qua movement's about 30° so you have
about 30° in the quaw and once it runs
out then you're going to change the
other the foot you're you're not going
to keep uh P pivoting that foot okay cuz
you'll go heel weight so I go back for
the absorption and then I have that
30° that I have on the quad and then
we're going to run out and so that's
when that
30° I now shift onto the front foot and
I get it on this foot do do you guys see
that so that's that's telling you what
you're going to do
so
one qua now he passes you
sorta so you have to get to the other
side of him you see when you shift your
weight you're now on the back of him
okay and then you bring him around in
that technique in that part you bring
him around and then there it
is so there's no straight on your
knee and yes he's on a circle but I'm
I'm not making in a
circle
okay so watch how I'm doing this on the
back foot that's the first yield starts
the rotation with the qua it's going to
run out shift onto the other foot quaw
again let him pause and you're
in double
pivoting it's it's not working and he
knows that's why it's he's smiling every
time I do this cuz there's no power I
have I have no ability to get him around
like that
okay but that's me making a
circle with my my hips rotate you see my
hips are rotating but they're using like
straight lines in a way to do
it so
one 2 3 four and it's so it's much
easier than you think
CU there's way less
movement okay try